Good morning, John, it's Tuesday- some day of some month.
I have something I need to get off my chest. There's always been ice on Mars! Everybody knows that there's ice on Mars!
It's just not news that there's ice on Mars!
Why is that news?
We've known for, like, 50 years that there's ice on Mars!
[sighs deeply] Okay.
[intro music]
Sorry.
Mars dork.
Mars has ice caps.
They're sometimes coated with carbon dioxide- like, dry ice- but at the core they're both made of water.
I don't why everyone thought that it was news that there's ice on Mars.
The news is that the lander landed on ice.
That's great news for the people who wanted to study the ice, but there- there's always been ice on Mars!
Anyway...couple weeks ago, I asked the Nerdfighters to use their collective brain cells and Googling-fingers to answer some question.
Wee-yoo.
And they did a remarkably good job at all but one of the questions.
And the one question that didn't get answered was pretty hard.
I asked what the difference between "mono" and "uni" were, and you guys knew that.
Apparently the big difference is that one is Latin and one is Greek, and I though they were both Latin.
Latin words use "uni" and Greek words use "mono."
Now, there were other people who indicated that "uni" often had a connotation of bringing many into one,
whereas "mono" was just one on its own.
Like, monomer is one thing all by itself, whereas university is many coming into one.
But does't work in every circumstance, like: unicycles only have one wheel.
It is not a mono-cycle.
But interesting nonetheless!
If, uh, you're interested in that kind of thing.
Continuing: trivia...uh, come from tri-via. I was right.
Tri-via. Three roads. And any place where three roads come together is often where people would get together and talk about...
They just gossip.
You know, chill out, hang out, talk about stuff that doesn't really matter.
Not very important stuff, but you know...trivia.
"Are there more murders on T.V. or in real life?"
Now that remains pretty much unanswered.
The general consensus is that real life probably has more murders, which, you know, is not what I would want to hear.
Per capita, television definitely has more murders.
If you're a character on television, your lifespan is significantly shorter than a person in real life.
Also, if you're at a party and Tony Shalhoub, or Angela Lansbury, or Hercule Poirot show up, just leave.
Leave... Leave.... Run away because I think your jewels are going to get stolen or you are going to get whacked!
I also ask whether evil people have pets.
Lots of evil people have had pets.
So lots of people knew about Hitler.
He had a dog named Blondi- a German Shepard (surprise)- that apparently went down the same way as he and his girlfriend:
through poison pill.
But, what you may not know is that Hitler had another dog...
named Fuchsl.
I'm not making it up.
So while Hitler was fighting in World War I, he was- he was, uh, working around the trenches and he found a little Terrier named Fuchsl, and he adopted it.
And later, Fuchsl was stolen from him.
Whoever stole Fuchsl may in fact have been responsible for Hitler turning out the way he did.
Probably not.
Nonetheless, it's hard to think that if you had a little Terrier named Fuchsl that you could be that much of a jerk.
Fuchsl.
[cute noises]
Lenin loved cats. He had lots of cats.
And while you may not think that Lenin is very evil, he did sort of open up the door for Stalin to take over after he died, which...not good.
However, there was some evil people that really, uh, hated pets.
For example, Mao, who you might not think is all that evil until I tell you this story.
He decided that all pets were a symbol of- of, bourgeoisie oppression and had them all killed, uh, in the sixties and seventies.
He killed tens of thousands of dogs and cats.
Even dogs and cats that were raised primarily for food.
Uh, he killed those as well.
Not that they would not have died.
So now you know the answers to all those questions!
I have a question for you.
I'm making a song about Star Trek, and it's longer than four minutes, and I can't get it any shorter.
So I'm going to have to impose the one longer-than-four-minutes clause, and that requires that there be a Nerdfighting montage.
So you can send me anything to do with Star Trek. Anything.
Preferably Next Generation, and preferably with Captain Picard involved.
[quiet grunt] That would be fantastic.
To sparksflyup@gmail.com so that the video can be longer than four minutes.
I promise it'll be worth it.
I'm very excited about the song.
John, I'll see ya soon.
Lenin's kitty says, "Click the little yellow box and subscribe!"